l'inflation galopante et les taxes
plombent le pouvoir d'achat des Français
il est grand
temps allez-vous entendre cette
inquiétude et cette souffrance qui monte
quelle mesure comptez-vous proposer ou
prendre c'est d'abord de répondre à
l'urgence du pouvoir d'achat c'est la
bataille du plein emploi nous avons une
chose en commun la volonté farouche de
faire évoluer notre société ce qui peut
être tout caractérise c'est de prendre
les problèmes tels qu'ils sont la
politique de baisse des impôts sur les
entreprises que nous avons entreprises
depuis 5 ans donne des résultats
vivez en direct et en intégralité les
questions des députés au gouvernement
mardi à 15 heures